hey youtubers is Charlie so brie
Larson's have been sharing pictures of
herself doing captain marvel things so I
thought it was time for a Captain Marvel
Avengers infinity war movie if you
didn't know that's the movie that she's
debuting in so here we go so everybody's
looking at this and they're like wait a
minute does this mean that they're gonna
do Kelly pseudo conics run for the
Captain Marvel movie so really just to
explain a timeline of how Captain Marvel
is going to appear in the Marvel
Universe if you guys didn't know she's
going to appear for the first time in
Avengers infinity war my guess is that
it would be spider-man style where she
gets the intro she may get her powers in
that movie because her powers aren't
like spider-man's powers because in the
context of power levels she's someone on
the level of vision or Scarlet Witch so
it would require like if they're not
going to do the comic book origin of her
powers which I'll explain in a second
they're going to have to use an infinity
gem which would merit like a really big
on-screen moment where she goes from
being Carol Danvers Air Force pilot to
Carol Danvers Captain Marvel Wonder
Woman of the Marvel Universe and if you
guys didn't know she's effectively been
used like the Wonder Woman of the Marvel
Universe up until recently now the
distinction is less clear like she's
just like a really super-powered person
in the Marvel Universe that's charged
with defending the earth she's like the
Avenger who lives in space and really
like the reason that I think that brie
Larson is reading this comic is one you
know because Kelly sued iconic she's a
great writer so it's a nice run but this
is actually not the current run of
Captain Marvel comics right now Civil
War 2 is going on and the people that
are writing the Captain Marvel comic are
the former show runners of agent Carter
is like a whole different story but the
whole idea is is that during Kelly sudha
conics run at the beginning of that iron
man comes to Carol Danvers and says you
know what I think we need an Avenger in
space I think that Rhodey would be
awesome for the job and she you know she
gets kind of pissed off because in the
comics she and Rhodey had a sexual
history together they've been boyfriend
and girlfriend for a long time but they
kind of broken up since then so she's
kind of having this midlife crisis and
it isn't really sure of her place in the
world where she belongs so she's like I
just need some time to myself to think
things over
so she's like okay I'm the best person
to go into outer space it becomes this
big crossover story with the guardians
of the galaxy but it ends with her
leading soar
which is kind of like the Galactic
version of shield so you've seen the
Marvel movie so far you've seen how Nick
Fury Coulson shield works in the Marvel
Universe imagine they start to learn
about more galactic threats the stuff
that's going on in the guardians of the
galaxy movies those you know those
movies have largely not been super
connected to what's going on on planet
earth but imagine they start to cross
over an Avengers infinity war so the
Avengers and the people of Earth like
the governments of Earth say we need
somebody in outer space to protect us on
a full-time basis so that whole arc like
the one Dupree Larson is reading right
here just kind of redefines Captain
Marvel's role in the Marvel Universe as
that person in outer space that's trying
to protect the earth from all the other
inner galactic threats so it sounds like
however on the outside you know she
debuts in The Avengers movie as Carol
Danvers and then infinity war happens
and they really like there's all these
galactic threats Thanos versus the
Avengers the earth realizes that they're
like a small pebble in the grand scheme
of things and they're like okay we need
some more guns in space Captain Marvel
you're the person for the job
and then we get the Captain Marvel movie
but just to chart the timeline if you
guys didn't know the phase three
timeline currently the first movie after
Avengers infinity war where Captain
Marvel is going to debut is going to be
ant-man and the wasp then Captain Marvel
is going to be like their spring 2019
movie then the next movie after the
Captain Marvel movie is the next
Avengers movie it's going to be you know
like new Avengers or whatever they're
going to pick for the title but in terms
of the way the character is introduced
to the Avengers think of it in a very
Spider Man Civil War type way like I
know a person and they go find that
person and that person just happens to
be Carol Danvers so what a coincidence
then the Kelly sued iconic introduced
her version of Captain Marvel in this
run in a spider-man crossover Peter
Parker and Carol Danvers have like this
one-off adventure in a spider-man comic
book before she debuts in this Captain
Marvel number one title so most of you
even if you don't read comics you've
probably seen her costume you have like
some vague idea about who she is but her
powers and her backstory are very
complicated also the story of how she
got the name Captain Marvel because
there have been several versions of the
Captain Marvel and the Miss Marvel
character so way back in 1967 in the
original Captain Marvel title Captain
Volume one number 18 she debuts as Carol
Danvers gets captured by the enemy of
Captain Marvel the original Creek
Captain Marvel his enemies trying to
hurt him so he captures Carol Danvers
takes her to this device called the
cyclo magnetron and it's like this magic
device for creating weapons of mass
destruction so he uses this energy
source to create this giant robot they
defeated everything blows up in Captain
Marvel escapes with Carol Danvers
but she's injured in the blast so the
energy from the device infuses her and
gives her powers she becomes Miss Marvel
so that was way back in the 1960s she
goes on to have adventures as Miss
Marvel becomes kind of like the Wonder
Woman of the Marvel Universe but then
much much later that Captain Marvel gets
cancer dies she takes his name Captain
Marvel as a way to honor him and then as
part of the transition she gets the new
version of the costume that most of you
are probably familiar with like the one
that brie Larson is wearing here but the
funny thing about that is that she's
actually a colonel in the military she's
not a captain she just uses the Captain
Marvel name is a way to honor the
original Captain Marvel so you see it's
very confusing just expect the movies to
cut through a lot of that like they'll
probably have some links to her origin
story from the comics it will probably
involve something from the Kree the
guardians of the galaxy the Infinity
stones so they'll just combine all that
and make it really easy to follow so for
those of you asking you don't need to go
back and read all these big runs you
don't even really need to read this
Kelly su Taconic run that brie Larson is
reading because it's this big crossover
with the guardians of the galaxy story a
lot of it is the story of how star-lord
basically a ousts his father from the
galactic empire in the comics his father
in the comics is going to be very
different from his father in the movies
so already were way off of comic book
story so don't worry about just expect
to see a lot of Easter eggs for her
comic book origin story in the movie
version of her origin story but here's
my question for you guys because she is
so powerful in the Marvel comics do you
think that they will use an infinity
stone as a way to give her her power in
the movies because the psyche magnetron
the device that gives her her powers in
the comics sounds like the energy that
you would find in an infinity stone like
that's how big and powerful
so it seems like it would be much easier
for them to just use an infinity stone
as the MacGuffin to give her her powers
in the same way that they use the mind
gem to give Scarlett which envision
their powers so it just remains to be
seen how big a part of infinity war she
is I imagine she'll probably be featured
in it at least as much as spider-man was
featured in Civil War so I'm expecting
her to get at least 20 to 30 minutes in
a two-and-a-half-hour movie just because
there's so much stuff happening infinity
war but for those of you asking now like
where is infinity war what stage of
development it isn't they didn't really
tease too much of it at Comic Con
so there are two infinity war movies
they just decided to change the title of
the second movie because it's going to
be so different the people that are
writing infinity war are also writing
the second movie at the same time so
they have two Avengers movies that
they're making at the exact same time
they might even shoot those back-to-back
but hopefully that answers that question
that they're basically finishing the
scripts for the first infinity war movie
right now
and the second one at the same time so I
would expect to hear more about the
movie when they finish those scripts
most of their attention for the rest of
this year is going to be spent promoting
Doctor Strange then guardians of the
galaxy which is like the next big movie
in the spring then spider-man homecoming
once we get closer to spider-man coming
out that's when you'll probably see them
hype the out of infinity war but
let me know in the comments when do you
think we're going to see the first
teaser for infinity war I'm just I'm
guessing that it's going to be after
spider-man homecoming hits theaters so
in related news giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Michael Demasi you and a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so my
next video will probably be for Suicide
Squad sequels what I think is going to
be happening with those characters but
if there's any more Marvel infinity war
Captain Marvel videos that you guys want
me to do just let me know in the
comments where you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn how the Deadpool sequel has
declared open war on all comic book
sequels especially infinity war and you
can click here for all my Suicide Squad
movie Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys